how was your your beautiful wife I see
you two all the time first of all thank
you for asking about my wife yeah she's
doing the Dale Carnegie classes are
really coming along I'm trying to be so
likeable she's doing well it's full of
surprises she came home you got a minute
she came home last week
she came home last week uh-huh
with a hair extensions hair extension I
didn't know she's trying to mix things
up or you know fool me yeah but they're
actually from a russian prostitute
really yeah but she did not tell me that
I recognized them she's very very
attractive woman she's got a lot of work
done uh-huh but we do we do have an
agreement we have a Hall Pass agreement
you love you guys know that is I heard
of the Hall Pass yeah it's a gonna cream
I was not assuming that I was your Hall
Pass
that's what that look was supposed to be
no that was not it okay hall pass
agreement is you could be with any one
celebrity for one night and no question
if the other celebrity if the celebrity
is willing then you can guess you have
to get the willingness from the other I
didn't think about that
usually what under duress yeah yeah I
forgot it think about that but but I did
realize that with a Hall Pass agreement
you have got to update that list and
keep it current because I didn't look at
my four-mile you know who mine was huh
Farrah Fawcett but hers is with Bruce
Jenner Bruce Jenner
what are you gonna do your pati whatever
to do what do you mean what are you
gonna do what is that your new thing
what are you gonna do oh that's your new
thing with you what are you gonna do
that's my catchphrase from the 80s you
get that from that show I was on no
you've never had what are you gonna do
because I would have told you that's
what are you gonna do
you